[Music]
in the summer of 1995
china sent a bunch of its troops to the
province of fujian they then started
testing missiles and putting it on tv
they then started running highly
publicized combat exercises very similar
to what it would look like to cross this
130 kilometer wide strait to invade the
island of taiwan a place that china
doesn't think is a real country but
rather a part of china itself a
rebellious island province in an
unfinished civil war another round of
chinese war games near taiwan has the
u.s and other nations concerned china
did all this saber-rattling because
taiwan's president had asked for a visa
to visit the united states and the u.s
congress voted to give it to him to find
beijing and undermining china's claim to
taiwan oh and taiwan was holding their
first democratic election these are the
first free elections of a chinese leader
in 5 000 china announced friday that it
would start the new military exercises
less than a week before taiwan's
presidential election china hated that
all of this was happening on this island
that they think is theirs hence all of
the military flexing but look who shows
up next diplomatic trouble may be
brewing again between china and the
united states
it's the us military and they're sending
their biggest show of military force in
asia since the vietnam war right here in
china's neighborhood president bill
clinton sent in all of the us's best
stuff aircraft carriers guided missile
cruisers destroyers powerful weapon
systems from the most powerful military
on earth so all of this concentrated u.s
military power comes into the region and
enters right here through the strait of
taiwan it was a response to china and
all of its efforts to intimidate taiwan
the message was very clear china we are
way more powerful than you so back off
and let taiwan do its thing and guess
what it totally worked china backed down
and the u.s reasserted itself as the
global powerhouse a power that no one
can mess with okay so now let's fast
forward to last fall a lot has changed
in this 20 or so years
and china is at it again flexing on
taiwan their favorite way of doing this
lately is flying military aircraft into
this air border taiwan's air defense
identification zone or ades an adaz is
airspace that if you enter you should
identify yourself or else the nearby
country will assume that you're coming
to attack them china has started flying
military aircraft over this airspace
without asking permission without
identifying themselves
not just like once or twice but like
dozens of times
per day
hundreds of times a month these are the
actual recorded flight paths of chinese
aircraft flying over taiwan's ada's and
then back to china it's a giant fu to
taiwan or rather
remember who's boss here
luckily there's some really amazing data
on every single one of these chinese
flyovers they're all documented taiwan's
air force scrambled again today this is
research from the foreign policy
research institute and it's incredibly
useful to see china's activity in
taiwan's ages you can see this massive
surge late last year in flyovers this is
a graph that shows every single time a
chinese jet has flown over taiwan's ages
in 2021 you can see that it comes to a
peak in the first week of october this
was the week that china was celebrating
its founding and they were sending a
very clear message to taiwan you will be
ours that week this chinese state-owned
publication comes out with this headline
time to warn taiwan secessionists and
their fomenters
war is real this is not fair play so
guess who shows up to the region to calm
things down a u.s warship has sailed
through the taiwan street
[Music]
so right after this huge bulk of
flyovers of taiwan's ages the u.s sends
in guided missile destroyers through the
taiwanese strait and they're accompanied
by a canadian ship worn off 25 chinese
aircraft that entered its defense zone
oh but this time it didn't work here's
when the u.s sailed through the strait
and here's what china does after tons
more flyovers of taiwan's adas looking
at the raw data you can see that these
flyovers start happening almost every
day
it's not the 90s anymore
things have changed bill clinton can't
just send a bunch of naval ships to the
taiwan strait and expect china to back
down we're living in a different era the
biggest difference is that china's
military has become way more powerful in
the last 20 years add to that that their
zeal for taking over taiwan to reunite
it with mainland china has grown
immensely every year since the reason
i'm telling you this story and showing
you the difference between how china
reacted in the 90s and how it reacted
last fall is because that difference is
really important if we want to think
about what war looks like in this region
i've been talking to military experts
i've been diving deep into military
reports and writings from the chinese
military itself to try to understand
what war with taiwan would look like
it's something that is becoming more
likely year by year so what's to follow
is my best attempt at understanding what
war in the taiwan strait looks like a
war that drags in the united states and
its allies war is impossible to predict
and so we don't know for sure but what i
hope we can do here is look at a
scenario and learn how conflict works
and what calculations all the countries
involved would have to make in what
might become the next world war i just
want to make china understand that we
are not going to step back china's
aggression against taiwan is
accelerating and it's blaming the u.s
raising has been getting increasingly
tough on taiwan so are you saying that
the united states would come to taiwan's
defense
yes and yes
hey before we dive into this i want to
say thank you to the sponsor of today's
video who made this video possible thank
you nordvpn for supporting this video a
vpn is a very useful tool that allows
you to connect to the internet but to do
so via a different country so when i'm
traveling i often want to get into my
email and my email doesn't like that i'm
in a different country they think i'm a
hacker trying to get into my email and
it's like no it's me this is one reason
i love nordvpn i can connect to nordvpn
and tell it to route my connection
through the united states so now my
email's like oh he's still in the united
states he's fine that's one reason i use
nordvpn the other
is because it allows me to access tons
more content there's a lot of stuff
whether gaming or like netflix that is
not available in my country but if i
route it through a different country i
get access to a ton more entertainment
options which is pretty cool nordvpn
also focuses on security and encryption
it doesn't throttle your speed so it
doesn't like slow your internet down
it's a very solid tool for security for
entertainment and for travel at least
that's how i use it oh and it's super
cheap there is a link in my description
it's nordvpn.com johnny harris if you go
there you can get a two-year plan at a
big discount plus a bonus gift which
will set you up with a very very good
deal and if you discover that this is
not useful to you or you don't like it
for some reason you have 30 days to get
all of your money back so there's no
reason why you shouldn't go try it go
click this link it supports this channel
when you do so and thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring this video and now
let's dive into this scenario about
potential war between taiwan and china
[Music]
okay i'm going to dive into a very
specific scenario of how conflict could
escalate in the taiwan strait but first
i have to say something i have to get
this off my chest which is i felt a
little bit conflicted making this video
i feel very against the sort of machismo
fascination with conflict like it's some
sort of cool good thing when at the end
of the day what we're talking about are
people's lives we were talking about
valuable taxpayer money we are talking
about the future of entire societies
being ripped apart by a power struggle
this is not sexy and cool this is a
nightmare secondly let us all just
acknowledge right now how easy it is to
dehumanize china and its leaders and its
military but let me just remind you that
china doesn't want war they don't want
bloodshed they will probably try much
less violent ways to try to force taiwan
to the negotiating table before
resorting to all-out invasion but the
reason i want to make a video about the
nightmare scenario because even if a
military has a goal for a less violent
intervention that's not how war works
conflict is very messy and one
miscalculation can lead to an escalation
in the conflict and now you have a
wildfire that is out of control on both
sides it's incredibly easy for the
momentum of conflict to bring us into
that kind of situation and that's why i
want to suss out what it could look like
okay those are my disclaimers let's dive
into this
[Music]
i'm gonna start rolling here i'm just
two okay i'm gonna clap here comes
okay i need to bring you over to my desk
to show you some documents i've been
staring at
any invasion of taiwan starts with this
document
this is a chinese law meant to stop any
parts of china from seceding from china
itself and it mentions taiwan
it basically says that if taiwan tries
to assert its independence from china or
and this is the most important part or
if the possibilities for a peaceful
reunification should be completely
exhausted that china shall employ
non-peaceful means and other necessary
measures to protect china's sovereignty
and territorial integrity translation if
they run out of diplomatic solutions
china is required by law to invade
taiwan and force it to reunite with
china and no i don't read or speak
mandarin but google translate come on
listen we're like 70 years into peaceful
solutions being tried and not working
meanwhile on the island of taiwan
support for any sort of reunification is
at an all-time low like it's not looking
like peaceful reunification is gonna
happen which is making the
interpretation of this law
more and more on the side of china
should do this forcibly okay so that's
the legal justification from a chinese
perspective pair that with the fact that
unlike in the 90s china now has a
massive military there's new concern at
the pentagon about china's military
buildup with all sorts of new missiles
china could soon be able to deploy a
nuclear-tipped missile that u.s defenses
would find much harder to detect tanks
helicopters submarines ships i mean this
isn't from me this is the us government
they recently came out with a report
that said that the chinese navy now is
bigger than the us's navy at least by
numbers they have 360 versus our 297
ships now caveat to that data our ships
are much bigger but still china's recent
military buildup is nuts and this is why
the u.s military is kind of freaking out
my opinion is this problem is much
closer to us than most
think we have to take this on with
urgency china is upping the ante on
taiwan and there are fresh fears of a
chinese invasion of taiwan taking over
taiwan remains china's number one
strategic priority
okay so this is the moment that a lot of
you probably came to this video for
which is what does the war actually look
like let's say that china feels
confident that the only way that taiwan
is going to join china which is again a
legal imperative is if they forcibly
invade blockade isn't working
negotiation isn't working the first
strike on taiwan would likely look like
just another chinese provocative aedes
flyover china's done this hundreds of
times so at this point taiwan thinks
that they're just doing another one of
their routine flex our military might
exercises but this time the fighter jet
turns towards the island and begins
firing at the same time china fires
guided missiles from the mainland and
deploys tons more jets and they all
start firing in a fast highly
coordinated attack the target here is
anything that taiwan can use to defend
itself like weapons that can shoot down
planes or boats that are coming onto the
island i mean this could be anything
radar communication nodes military
command centers navy bases bridges
communication networks power stations
even government buildings they would
have a wide variety of targets to
effectively deny taiwan the ability to
respond effectively i mean unfortunately
for taiwan a lot of these targets are
left out in the open they're easy to see
a runway is really easy to see and
really hard to hide this first attack
would happen
very quickly one military expert ian
easton put it very succinctly when he
said assuming the intent is invasion
these attacks could be expected to be
concentrated in a short time frame as a
prelude to invasion with no pauses other
than those required for moving reloading
and repairing equipment
sounds horrible so taiwan's leaders are
caught off guard and they immediately
retreat underground to a command bunker
where they can plan their response
luckily china will not be able to take
out all of their military targets some
of their aircraft hangars are deep in
mountains and some of their missile
sites are really well camouflaged they
would escape the bombardment so taiwan
would have the ability to respond they
would likely be able to get some air
power into the air and fire some
missiles towards mainland china to hit
air bases radar and military batteries
on the mainland at this point taiwan
also sends troops to their western
beaches to start laying mines and
preparing for an oncoming barrage of
chinese troops who are probably now on
their way across the strait this has all
happened within just a few hours and the
u.s is just barely hearing about this
china has likely jammed much of the
communication channels that would allow
the us to have a clear picture of what's
going on this will slow their response
time the thing is china has gotten
really good at sending little robots up
to satellites in space their civilian
satellites to like help repair them they
could use the same technology to latch
on to an american spy satellite and
block its ability to view what's
happening on the ground yes we're now
talking about conflict in space as a
feasible part of the scenario so the u.s
is trying to get up to speed the u.s
president and military leaders now have
to decide how they're going to respond
are they going to risk american lives to
protect this far away island it's
something that the american public
broadly would not be into but they have
to do something they have to make a plan
meanwhile back over in the strait
taiwan's military assets are severely
damaged and china is now sending
hundreds of thousands of troops and
loads of supplies across this 130
kilometer stretch of water they're using
boats of all kind military boats
merchant boats that don't need to defend
themselves because taiwan can't respond
adequately and each of these vessels is
carrying tons of supplies and troops but
again on taiwan's western beaches there
are probably taiwanese troops who have
been planting mines ready for this
invasion so there's now a battle on the
beaches as chinese amphibious attackers
try to hit the beaches and push back the
taiwanese defense we're going to
continue assuming taiwan doesn't give up
and capitulate and surrender to china at
this point if that's the case the u.s is
now just starting to respond likely from
their bases in the region japan and guam
they deploy aircraft carriers with jets
and bombers stealth fighters as well as
fast attack submarines that will focus
on one thing hitting all of these ships
the ones that are bringing stuff and
people across the strait japan and
australia likely come in as allies to
help out on this defense and now the us
and its allies are in direct combat with
china two nuclear nations fighting each
other this is exactly what we try to
avoid because we don't know where it
goes from here we don't know where the
ceiling is war always escalates and when
there's nuclear weapons involved that's
a very scary momentum there's even a
scenario where china actually strikes
first hitting us bases in japan and guam
at the same time that they hit their
initial targets in taiwan this would be
a much more provocative move and would
certainly bring the us full force into a
war with china so now you have chinese
troops who have pushed back the
taiwanese defense on the western beaches
and they are now moving in towards major
city centers the us is fighting on the
water and in the air and from here it
becomes impossible to predict what could
happen next there are so many different
directions depending on the us's
tolerance for bloodshed there could be
american troops on the ground trying to
push back chinese advancements inland
but if you look at chinese military
writings on this you'll see that as a
part of this scenario when they're
thinking about it they're not just
thinking about the us and its allies in
taiwan they also predict that india will
take advantage of this moment of chaos
and invade the himalayan borders to the
south they even foresee tibetan freedom
fighters way out here in the west who
have long been hostile towards chinese
rule rising up and taking advantage of
the instability to gain back control of
their region i mean you can see how this
starts to unfold before you know it the
entire region is devolving into a war
that threatens to engulf many more
countries hundreds of thousands of lives
and this is where i want to stop because
from here it just becomes so speculative
as to be completely useless but i tell
you this scenario of a potential
invasion of taiwan not because it's the
most likely it's actually not the more
likely situation is china will pressure
taiwan through blockades or through
other painful pressures that will get
them to come to the negotiating table i
tell you this because this scenario is
still absolutely a possibility what's
scary to me about all of this and i've
said this a bunch but i'm just gonna
keep saying it once something like this
starts it's really hard to reverse it to
put the cat back in the bag no one's in
control that's a concept that's really
hard to get your head around if you
didn't live through a global war we live
in an international system that feels
like it has rules we have the un we have
treaties and conventions we have global
trade it feels like there's some sort of
order but let me remind you that that's
because we live in the most peaceful
time in human history this long piece
where few people alive today witnessed
what it looks like when two powerful
countries clash in all-out war it
usually happens when some powerful
leader feels strongly that he deserves
land that the rest of the world says
isn't his so he uses his big powerful
army to go take it and in the process he
sparks a horrible tragedy and while i
hope more than anything that doesn't
happen in this case we have to remember
how commonplace it is and that the peace
between these big powers is actually the
outlier here i really hope that we are
past needing to resort to this version
of conflict to settle our disputes at
this time in our history but i'm not
totally convinced that we are yet and i
think china and taiwan this specific
case is the best thing to look at to
test whether or not we we can we can
talk about it we can find creative ways
to solve this instead of resorting to
the thing humans have done forever which
is just fight each other and see who
wins
[Music]
okay so i appreciate you watching this
video and would love to hear your
thoughts um i left a bunch of sources
down in the description where you can
read a lot more about this from
the really good research and reporting
that has been done on this topic i've
got a bunch more videos coming out in
the next month so stay tuned and
subscribe if you're not already
i also have luts and presets which are
in the link in my description they are
how i color my videos and photo if you
are interested in that um i also have a
storytelling course where i go into my
thoughts on storytelling that is all in
the description you can check it out and
um that's it thanks for watching i'll
see you in the next one